foreign
do some Tick Tock reaction videos and it
looks like the videos they have queued
up for me today are feminist dating
videos and you know the way this used to
work is that uh my producers would we're
doing some kind of tick-tock reaction
they'd say well do you want to react to
uh these kinds of videos and I would say
yes or no but at this point they don't
even ask me anymore because I think they
know that I'll just say no uh because
I'll if they said well do you want to
sit there for 10 minutes and react to
feminist dating videos I would say I'm
not no I'm not going to do that I don't
care if it's good content I'm not I'm
not gonna put myself through that and so
now there's no conversation it's just uh
the videos are put up in front of me and
and here we are so we're going to go
through uh some of these videos of
feminists talking about their dating
experiences and giving dating advice go
ahead why do you think men care about a
woman's body count do you
hear about that men in general
you ask me a body count he
who gives up oh my God that's so stupid
people actually ask that
yes you okay well then you're talking to
the wrong man
if a man is ever asking about your body
count you're talking to the wrong man
and he can get like that's so
stupid
can I ask you this then yeah sure so
what do you think about the analogy if
one key can open many locks it's known
as a master key as opposed to if you
have a lock that can be opened by any
key it's a good luck
I think that if if a woman is an analogy
to you then you're not ready to be
talking to a woman and you should
probably get so if a woman is the key to
you
talk to your mom talk to your sister
talk to your cousin I don't know get a
real life
and get thank you
and a woman is not a key
thank you
um
so
a few issues here red flags if you're a
single man looking for uh the the woman
of your dreams and someone that you
might want to spend the rest of your
life with uh this this is not going to
be it before we even get to the content
of what is being said when you when you
come across a woman who cannot say two
words without dropping an F-bomb you can
get like that's so stupid
go the other direction like as fast as
you can uh that's gonna tell you
everything you need to know about it and
and yeah now it's also bad if there's a
man who can't say two two words not
saying enough driving F1 it's worse for
a woman though
um it just is you
and that's also advice for women in
general so if you if you are having
trouble finding uh a man you might want
to think also about how you're
presenting yourself how you're speaking
and you see their the problem but then
we look at the content of what she's
saying if someone even
refers to it as their body count body
count of course if you're an old uh fogy
Like Me Maybe you aren't familiar with
this lingo here but body count means the
number of people you've slept with you
ain't even trying to compare body counts
why
should I keep going all day I'm out I'm
out now we call that body count if
you're talking to someone who even uses
that phrase to describe their past
sexual encounters it doesn't matter what
the number is again go the other way so
it could be if you're in a dating world
if you're a man talking to a woman it's
a good thing maybe to ask her to say uh
what's your body count because if she
says anything other than words to the
effect
what are you talking about that's not
how like if she reacts that way to that
question it's a good sign
if she drops a number oh here's my body
count starts talking about her body
count but whatever the number is it's
bad I can think of nothing of a more
dehume it's like it is literally
dehumanizing okay now you're just
referring to they're not people they're
not people who had a sexual encounter
with it's uh it's it's not that they're
just bodies right body count that
usually means dead it's usually
referring to people who've been killed
it's not you're imagining this
dead bodies in your wake that's the kind
of like image that comes to mind so
someone who speaks that way is already
another big red flag
but yes
uh no matter how we put it if you're
talking to a woman who's had many random
sexual encounters then uh then yeah
that's not someone who you want you know
it's look people can be reformed they
can change they can go through like a
conversion experience people can change
we have to allow for that well if it's
going to help end all of this madness
I'll allow it but um a woman like this
especially who doesn't even want to
consider the possibility that it might
be wrong to conduct yourself This Way
well then you know that tells you
everything you need to know about her
character her her self-respect or lack
thereof just before you even get two two
words into this we've got you know 50
different Red Flags uh all right let's
go to the next one do you reach for your
purse on the first date
yes always
to show my fake kindness
you know better no I don't pay for any
first day you asking me out but you
don't even do that I'm not gonna pretend
no you know what it is yeah the date is
like 100 you'll be fine oh you you think
that I go to a restaurant on a first
date you're assuming that I date men
that would take me to a restaurant yeah
but my hand never like gets to the purse
yeah you don't touch I don't touch it I
like play pretend and then I'm like oh
there then they pay yes of course I do
it it's like a guilt thing I always
reach to like show them well okay the
other day I dug around in here I felt my
wallet and I just kept digging
I was waiting for me to finish digging
you finally just paid but I wanted him
to think I was nice yes and then of
course they pull it out and I say oh are
you sure well are you sure is good if
they don't pay for it on the first date
just the first date I'd say no second I
just think that's weird third day we can
start talking about that what so you
okay first of all you you
you expect them to pay on the first date
but then by the third date you could
talk about them not paying so you want
them to be less invested as the date as
time goes on should it be the other way
around if anything that on the first
date when they don't even know you like
they're they're not going to pay and
then but then as you start to have a
relationship now they are paying
wouldn't wouldn't you expect that to be
the way that that evolves oh he's the
captain obvious guy but in general I'm
an old-fashioned person I believe in
Chivalry I believe in all that I believe
in gender roles I do gasp yeah I can say
I think in you know all things being
equal uh it makes sense for the man to
pay but you as a woman
cannot expect that you cannot demand
that you have no right to be
disappointed if you don't get it unless
you also believe in Chivalry and believe
in gender roles what you cannot do as a
woman now here's some real mansplaining
as a woman
pointing at you you cannot
recoil at the very idea of gender roles
but then expect them to pay because
guess what cupcake that's a gender role
so you can't you know what I'm going to
discard all the gender roles that have
to do with me but then expect the man to
still abide by every gender role that
will benefit me that doesn't work you
don't get to do that y'all can't have it
both ways man so if you want to be an
enlightened Progressive feminist woman
who I don't believe in gender roles men
and women are exactly the same then pay
for your own damn meal that's it you
can't expect a man to you know it it
takes two to tango this goes two ways
gender roles do not just apply to one
person you don't get to you don't get to
get rid of all the generals except for
the one where you get to have a free
meal okay no so if you are a traditional
minded woman
and you comport yourself that way uh and
and
um you fulfill your end of the bargain
you know part of being chivalrous for a
man is to be a man of dignity and a man
of uh who who commands respect and acts
in a respectable way if you also are
that way as a woman which means that
you're not dropping f-bombs you're not
talking about your damn body count guess
what if you have a body count that you
refer to that way you are precluded from
having anyone pay for a meal for you
you're not you're not that kind of woman
sorry I'm sorry I'm not sorry but if you
comport yourself with dignity and you
believe in Tradition you know you
believe that men are men and women are
women and that's how you act and you
expect and you want to find a man who
has those same values great that's
perfect that's the way it should be
but
you gotta you gotta do you gotta you
have to hold up your end of the bargain
you just do in the not too distant past
private citizens used to be largely that
if you can imagine private what's
changed well the internet changed think
about everything you've ever searched
for watched or tweeted on the internet
now imagine all of that data being
crawled through collected and aggregated
by Third parties into permanent public
records to keep my data private when I
go online I use expressvpn there are
hundreds of data Brokers out there whose
sole business involves buying and
selling your data they don't even have
to tell you who they're selling it to or
get your consent either one of these
data points is your IP address data
Harvesters use your IP to uniquely
identify you and your physical location
but you can mask your IP address with
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes my
connection through an encrypted server
that makes it more difficult for third
parties to find me if it sounds
complicated it's not because all you
have to do is just tap one button on the
app and then you're protected so if like
me you believe that your data is your
business secure yourself with the number
one rated VPN on the market use MyLink
expressvpn.com Walsh YT to get three
extra months free that's exp RSS vpn.com
Walsh YT dating apps the place where we
all go because we're living in a
capitalist Hull where we have neither
the time nor the sense of community to
actually meet people at IRL hi it's
Celine chica let's unpack the downfall
of society who went in the Bible stop it
stop it
uh she said we're gonna unpack she said
let's unpack so we're going to move on
from that I have no tolerance for this
let's unpack the moment you say that I
tune out I don't care what you're about
to say next you could be maybe you're
about to unveil the secrets of the
universe maybe you have a cure for
cancer the moment you say let's unpack
if you said if you came to me and said I
have a cure for cancer let's unpack it
I'm going to say get I don't want to
hear it get out of my face get out of my
face I'll get inside your face here's
why dating is a feminist feels
impossible sometimes and what to do
about it I'm Lily a top Matchmaker
turned intersectional feminist dating
coach and this question right here is so
important hi Maggie new friend we've
dm'd about her question let me read it
out to you I took notes so you're
feeling apathy like dating all right
stop it this is already taking too long
I'm already bored just go to the next
one did you know that is demographic of
people
children who aren't married that live
alone welcome back to part two of things
I learned from my feminist mother you do
not need to get married
my mother was born in 1952. for the
first 22 years of her life women were
not allowed to have their own bank
accounts or credit cards
this changed in 1974 thanks to Ruth
Bader Ginsburg when I was a little girl
I was obsessed with Disney and the idea
that somewhere out there was a prince
who was coming to rescue me each and
every time I would bring up this fantasy
my mother would quietly and gently
remind me sweetie it's okay if you never
get married she told me that marriage
was not all it was cracked up to be and
that happily ever after was more often
an image that people painted rather than
a reality and now thanks to that lesson
I fall into the demographic of the
happiest people on the planet oh what a
sure five years old I live alone I am
not married nor have I ever been married
and I don't have any children it's
pretty fantastic oh yeah really you're
exuding happiness when people reference
maybe see the prince charming never came
for you because uh because you your
hairstyle you look like a My Little Pony
so that maybe if you hadn't done that
then you would have had the prince
charming uh can you imagine this
I think you want to make fun of it
really because it's it's like she had no
chance in life you got a mom when you're
a little girl and you're watching the uh
princess you know movies as all little
girls like my own three-year-old
daughter is going through the phase
right now that in my experience can last
for like three years where she only
wears princess I have not seen her wear
anything but a princess costume for the
last four and a half weeks she wears it
to bed she wears it she will not wear
anything else but do you imagine going
up to a little girl watching the
princess you know is into the princess
thing and then saying you know um uh you
know that's that's that's not real you
won't be you won't be happily ever after
in fact in fact little little child
you'll be better off living alone and
dying alone that's what leave good for
you
so she claims that the happiest
demographic are middle-aged
single women who live alone are the
happiest
I guess this is one of those what's the
source trust me bro that's the I guess
this is one of those situations because
there's no it's not like it's it's hard
enough to measure happiness and so
anytime you hear a new study indicates
this or that about happiness happiness
who's happy who's not happy it's just
like it's impossible to actually measure
that scientifically especially across
entire demographics what's the level of
happiness in this demographic it's not
possible to actually do that in the
first place I mean the only way you can
even begin to measure happiness is to is
to is to interview ask people survey
people and say are you happy with this
Services
it tells you what people will say about
their happiness and so if this is true I
don't know what study she's been let's
just pretend she's basically on some
study that found that uh single
middle-aged women without children who
live alone are the happiness let's
pretend there's some study that says
that and probably there is because the
study says anything what that tells you
is that single middle-aged women without
kids who live alone are the most likely
to tell you when you survey them that
they are happy but that doesn't mean
that they actually are and in fact in
this case we're pretty sure that it
doesn't because they have a vested
interest in insisting that they are
happy they want you to think that
they're happy because they don't want to
publicly confront their own unhappiness
and it also it isn't this is where we
can we don't need to study we can use
our own Common Sense on our own
understanding of human nature
to know that um is very very rare to
find like I say it's impossible there's
all you know people are there are some
there are some people who have a
vocation where they're called to you
know uh to be Hermits living in the
woods somewhere or writing the Next
Great American novel I don't know like
those kinds of people exist but for most
people
um happiness is shared it is something
that we find
um in our relationships and especially
our relationships with our families
that's how we're human beings this is
how we are meant to be
um and so when you reject that you are
going to be lonely and you're not going
to be happy so instead you'll dye your
hair pink and blue and you'll make Tick
Tock videos insisting otherwise which is
you know that's the number one
indication someone isn't happy if
someone is on Tick Tock saying I am
happy that's the least happiest person
that you'll come across so
[Music]